tonight there is a new episode of
married at first sight on lifetime this
is one of my favorite shells and I just
want you to think about the premise
getting legally married to a complete
stranger now for season one favorite
Jamie and Doug their marriage started
out as a complete disaster but it turned
into a real-life love story I'm going
back to day one I'm going back to her on
the ground crying okay yeah in a fetal
position in a fetal position could you
believe you could turn around to this
moment yes I person I genuinely thought
I made the worst decision of my life you
are not to Pat myself on the back but
from day one where she was crying three
days later she was in my pants we waited
till we got married to have sex
king of the sarcastic judgment I was one
of the many people who thought no way
this married at first sight couple would
ever last
oh just eventually Jamie and Doug became
a happily married couple they celebrate
their five-year wedding anniversary next
week and have an adorable 18 month-old
daughter named Henley the couple has
also been very candid about their
struggles to start a family
we've lost our firstborn son Jonathan at
17 weeks I delivered him and we got to
you know you know hold him and he was
just perfect I didn't know how to to go
on from there I was seeing this little
person comes from this crazy social
experiment of a show it's so funny just
to think how when how are we gonna
explain but you know I think that the
moral of the story really is that I
think at the end of the day is love
comes in the strangest ways do I want my
daughter to marry stranger no I don't
really marriage has not been easy for
those two but they have worked through
all their issues and I love it